all right we got liftoff all right here
we go
okay here we go yeah here we go actually
see his white all right let's go don't
don't burn too much time in the opening
oh maybe he doesn't realize that he's
realized maybe he doesn't realize that
the game is started uh I I see his
screen it looks like he's thinking okay
okay okay we have liftoff okay so II for
c5 okay so he is not going to get to
play his scotch because hutch is going
for a Sicilian here so he's gonna have
to mix up his opening a bit okay so he
plays Bishop e5 very very good so far
mm-hmm I don't know what line hutch
plays now we do so he's going for d6
here xqc has this pin he can do very
normal moves here and play d3 he can
castle he can develop his knight he
can't go wrong it can trail I like I
like this opening start to the game from
xqc
he's definitely doing completely fine
just has to castle the king and then
bring the ax forces on the Queen side
into the game right I'm just
highlighting those four chats Oh hutch
playing very quickly he has more than
ten minutes on the clock here we got a
lot of it has everyone just been wearing
black and white today I don't know
what's going on today we are trying out
I think everyone has been yeah um with
it with our chess boards over here I
eventually you just start playing the
game so much and those are the only
colors you end up wearing chat so be
warned
g6 so he's prepared to bring his Bishop
to g7 mm-hmm and here I would like to
see xqc continued development he can
also make pawn pushes but I would feel
better about his chances here if he
prioritizes developing pieces right
exactly yeah
yeah no but I like what I'd like what
he's done so far it's it's pretty good
it's pretty good now now the one thing
that I've said is he has trouble it's
one thing I've said is he's had trouble
developing that's working this night on
the other side as long as he follows
that plan he gets peace developed this
is this will be a very good start for
him so I I like what I've seen thus far
what his idea is here is gonna be tricky
well let's take a listen in on his
stream and hear how he's thinking about
the opening okay so he wants to bring
his Bishop out but hutch will bring his
Bishop first so he has a block ooh
better I'm taking it
both of those are fine but the only
issue was pushing the prodigy is to see
that he pushes a pawn in the center
deeper she's not gonna be easy here
right after he moves his bishop and he
has that support well he doesn't like
that
so xqc likes going for the early pond
pushes my queen takes peace yeah so far
he's doing really good for double-double
beautiful takes takes the tank he's got
his mojo back he's confident ice is what
we like to see no I like I like what's
going on so far this is very very good I
blocked all through his attacks I
blocked all three of his main plans now
he has to wing it and now you've denied
on the spot because he doesn't think it
he doesn't he doesn't thing like that
he's a perfect one-dimensional he
prepares attacks I want to be funny
who's away oh my god oh my god what am I
gonna do now my god bang it bang it
no no don't be greedy what you want to
push or develop first I want to see him
devolve yeah I'm with you there it just
feels more likely to get him further
less blunder opportunities
seven minutes one figured are you
worried about his clock situation at all
um a little bit just cause yes he is to
play a straight idea he needs to come
with an idea where he can play the next
couple of moves very quickly in general
with positions completely fine but he
does need to have a little bit more
bully I mean it's still a good move we
just want to make sure he develops on
time so right kind of one issue is that
he's on one side of word are not
developed in terms of the brook tonight
in the bishop
but overall I do like what we've seen so
far right and the reason why you want
him to develop his pieces from your
experience watching xqc is that
something he tends to forget yeah more
often than not he does tend to forget
that he has to bring all the forces into
the game and with it with a knight the
[__] from the rook undeveloped there
are there are gonna be some issues down
the road potentially true and here the
most natural move for hutch is likely to
just grab the pawn here but it's not the
most accurate one because then he does
actually help xqc bring his knight into
the center he also creates these two
isolated double ponds that are going to
be under a tag right away from the white
knight exactly yeah so I think the
correct move here is Knight to d5 but
it's it's a difficult position both
sides have chances it's not really
clear-cut in terms of what they're gonna
what's gonna happen okay so Hodge plays
95 which is an excellent move and it's a
little bit dicey already potentially for
ecstasy because it's very natural to
take this pawn here on d6 but when you
do that black takes back and the rook
opens up so um hopefully he plays a move
like d4 freeing up his bishop in case he
doesn't fian Cairo it and also putting
another pawn in the center here
and it does strike me like a move that a
QC would see because he's used to doing
it in the Scotch right I think certainly
White House to plan the center of the
board but it is it is kind of dicey
already tough position very tough
position I think block is actually quite
a bit better already if we're looking at
the objective evaluation I think the bar
even says so but it's just it's a tough
position for white to find a plan and
this is one thing
excuse e needs to remember to do is I
mean probably he should put the bishop
on b2 here but see on cheeto cheeto
yes exactly the bishop house chat the
sniper house whatever you want to call
it right exactly yeah so probably he
should he should do that or he can push
the pawn those are really the two best
moves that I see here but he's got to
move he's got to make a move pretty soon
he's already very low on low on time
here this is this is the problem he's
high he's a lot of the time so far I
don't like c4 because he is opening up
his rook which has no squares to defend
with right now it's still a tricky move
though but if black plays something like
night before or you can even go Knight
f4 I think Knight f4 might actually be
winning for block here because if to
move the Queen and then there's probably
something on the diagonal but whether
hutch finds her or not what remains to
be seen
okay hutch plays Knight c7 which is also
a pretty natural move just moving his
knight away and now he has the
opportunity to play Bishop b2 so he
doesn't have to worry about his rook
getting trapped exactly and I think
Bishop b2 is it's definitely the best
move here too to counteract that Bishop
on g7 the the dark bishop so I think at
this point xec is doing completely fine
I like his position it's all pretty good
I mean it's worth objectively but he's
doing pretty well and he's not he's not
losing the game and we're already 10
moves in so I I'd be very pleased if I
if I were X you see at this point yeah
yeah we're on move 10 so let's see if he
makes it another 10 on to move 20 we had
a lot of doubters in the chat but so far
he's hanging on here he just has to move
faster Knight c3 also a good move very
good move yeah very very good move let's
take another listen on xqc stream
that's that no now I don't live in fear
anymore there's now even if he threatens
this I can still move it now I'm not
living in fear anymore
I think Phil threatened to do the same
to him by moving upwards trending this
putting interesting in a very bad
position for Queen check switcheroos I
mean it gets fun I like that he's
thinking on hutches time also this King
has to take this persona in fact spa
because then I think you children in
situation that's gonna be a little tough
yeah like pawn to h3 is probably the
best move here was very hard move
defying although I feel like I did I did
tell him about the interesting point
mere inches a plant and you know we keep
talking about how h3 is a hard move to
find I think I'm just gonna show it to
every single person I coach from now on
just like a reminder you get in just
kick that Bishop out of the way don't
worry about it
take take he's got something under just
leave it it does that that's really
[__] bad but anyways no checkmate
that's right we're good okay that's very
impressive
okay my queen isn't gonna good spot her
she loves this no but that's what he dig
the ball
I mean this is still fine as long as he
takes with the Queen yes yes how much
fun I take this
he takes pawn for free we don't like
free things I feel like he's psyching
himself out of it and that's why he's
playing so slowly
right now this is good okay so now I can
take the pawn on c6 he's still very much
in the game here there's a free pawn on
c6 that he can capture yeah it's very
good very very good yeah awesome play it
one big good fart again the one thing he
is remembered I'm the bishop and the
room still tied up as is very good now
I'm defending a juicer I bet he doesn't
like that four minutes on the clock
though yeah he's down he's down on time
but he's doing very very well on the
board I'm very very pleased to see this
again the one thing he's got to remember
is he has to bring that bishop and that
rook into the game he can't simply leave
those pieces underdeveloped for the
whole game right and now hutch is the
one thinking
I mean hutches plan now has gotten
harder and I think this is aware even
hutch might have some difficulties
finding a plan ideas like 96 94 I mean
it would really improve the position in
the placement of his visas which is
actually something we talked about in
our lesson in terms of general strategy
so as a coach I would be very happy for
him to make those kinds of slow improve
the position of your pieces right right
but I think also hutch is probably a
little bit caught off guard by ecstasy's
plate so far because he hasn't actually
made any major blunders he's played very
very good moves and at this point I
think I I'm very I'm very pleased with
what ecstasy has done this has been a
big improvement on the last game that he
played so I like what he's done he's not
worse were almost 15 moves into the game
your prediction is definitely gonna come
true here there's no ways in the lose
before move 25 so it's it this is
definitely been a big success for him
there you go chat doubters you know
where the door is you know where it is
show yourselves up
okay so Hutch taking his time here if he
gets even close to like five minutes and
xqc is only down by one minute that's a
very good sign for white yeah I think
it's just the fact that ideas are not
clear-cut here for black in fact like
1964 is the most obvious idea as a
strong hustler but otherwise it's not
it's not so clear like what what else
you can do it I it's not a natural kind
of attacking idea so I think right now
it's important that X you see makes a
couple clicks moves he should develop
the bishop here if he goes Bishop b2 and
they brings the rook into the game it's
anyone's game
yeah there should be to chat that's the
move we need to see here he is
protecting his knight so he can take
back with the bishop he won't double his
pawns he's developing his bishop on the
longest diagonal and he's freeing up
space for his rook to bring it into the
game later on right exactly yeah I can't
ask for anything better than three nice
ideas in one move and he sees it awesome
very very nice okay and now again hutch
has a 96 94 idea and if he doesn't play
something like that I mean he can make
slow moves like rook e8 a rook to b6
honestly to attack the Queen um it's a
move that makes no sense yeah I now
actually see news remember to bring the
Queen backwards not to the side of the
board to keep it in the center part of
the board very importance if he goes to
the side the rook is gonna trap the
Queen yeah that's that's true because
and the reason why I don't think about
rook b6 is because okay it has one
threat the Queen moves away and then the
rook is on a poor square but it does
have a direct threat that xqc has to
play against and there is a possible
trap correct so yeah this is where any
of the Queen moves backwards along this
diagonal are very important I think he's
gonna find it he's got three minutes on
the clock he's hovering over a four come
on man just do it yeah after is also
fine either way just to not go under the
Queen here all right yeah and the reason
why Queen a4 is the blunders because of
rook a six the Queen is under attack it
can't go too
b5 because of the night can't go to c6
because of the rook d7 the Queen
yeah the rutger queen it's very sad
trapped Queen if it goes to a for right
all right but he does see it and see
that he should bring the Queen back to
you for so that's a good move I think
he's gonna be like stop stop doubting
yourself just do it just move yes
we told the doubters where the door is
but you need to get that self-doubt out
also three perfect yeah I mean basically
the main thing is probably Queenie for
subjectively a better move but it's just
mainly don't make a blunder that's gonna
end the game here and so far the great
thing about the position is that it
doesn't really lend itself to big
mistakes because it's a very closed
position both sides have a lot of pawns
on the board so he should be able to see
he should be able to see the next couple
of moves here pretty quickly like bring
the roots to the center of the board um
and I I like what's going on
I really do bring their works to e 1 and
D 1 and that's absolutely perfect all
right well we're bringing XQ C's audio
on we're not changing scenes but we're
gonna be able to hear what he has to say
or his his tunes that's good too he's
getting too
he's hovering the rookie car I think
work do you one's gonna happen moving
down this yeah either work moved here is
it doesn't really matter you just gotta
cause it's all that move one of the road
oh no no no no no no no no why do you
why do you think that these kinds of
moves are are tough to see these kinds
of positions nice job yeah I mean I
don't know if it's so hard I think
that's a good place I think it's that he
doesn't trust himself that's the main
thing okay so much time not another
sentence it's not a great move but if we
have to do something they could have
been better some some ASM are there for
you chat how much time okay I like that
he noticed it doesn't matter if it's the
best move or not he just has to be fast
that is the right attitude to have right
yeah he needs to put the other roof in
this in the center of the board as well
but this has been a very very good game
I'm very very pleased now moves the
other roof over to e1 I think it's what
a idea should be and I I'm not sure that
he's actually doing he's much worse here
oh no his bishop unfortunate however
it's it's still only two pieces for the
rooks if Bishop takes Bishop you play
Knight takes rook and and it's still not
clear it's so more clear I do expect
hutch to take the bishop but hutch may
take the knight so there's a lot going
on here right and if he takes the knight
then he shouldn't capture back he should
capture the bishop it'll look like a
position in the puzzle rush
he was just practicing okay so I saw the
right notes right so of course you take
take the rook yes no the key here is to
bring the other books of center if you
can
yeah a move like rookie 1 we're getting
to 20 move soon chat so he's certainly
putting up a good fight a long game he
survived the opening and even the middle
game is interesting despite usually you
want to be decided with two pieces hutch
is technically worth upon worth and
material but it's still complicated
exactly yeah she's thinking here got a
move yeah Queen b7 good move
yeah it's a move that doesn't create any
weaknesses and I think that should be
the goal for him so don't push the pawns
in front of the king right away
necessarily d4 is just hanging upon a
four I guess technically is okay as well
yeah this is very good though this has
been a very very good very good start
from X you see and even now I mean hutch
is already down to three minutes as well
so there are there are there is a
possibility of blunders I know with
hutch I think he tends to be one of the
slower players and so we we haven't
really seen him with very little time
okay plays 98 which is is not a move
that I like the Queen trade are you
happy with that does it because it
reduces you know chances of getting
mated or serious blunders but I mean I I
think I think it's fine I I don't just
like it obviously in a general sense
it's very difficult for 4x you see here
but his moves become easier hutch is
starting to use more time so it's gonna
be an interesting finish here cuz I
think it'd happen we're gonna go to xqc
fullscreen
oh come on she's been putting some
pretty good bangers on today yeah before
interesting decision fast food that's
what I am I think boards
ok good move just develop it's a team
next move - G - mm-hmm now Rick a7 is a
very good move here for black but it's a
very hard to define
hutch took with the right pawn otherwise
his rook was in trouble hutch also
speeding up xqc actually plays pretty
well in time pressure he hasn't made
mistakes yet yeah he's also a little bit
lucky that's a very simplified time
position very cheap he sits on the board
as well
so this meant good game it's been a very
good game
a4 is a good move to taking a four yeah
I like the ideas he's considering here
and I'm impressed that he got his King
to stay square two very important to end
game right easy to pawn to e5 switch
next move so this is also very important
I know a rookie 7 it's very difficult to
play but it's not an easy move and hutch
missed a few times already so Oh a 5 85
85 85 come on 85 only idea and you saw
the idea okay it looks like he's gonna
push g4 here yeah
oh no he takes takes and even takes take
these get push up nah he did it mites my
game I'd like a pair of I want to do hi
the game I'm looking man I'm the chief
down the warlord is human and my candy
did it
Breen's ladies like oh no hi star Ricky
no no it takes
oh my god I don't think about that today
relax thanks for the game okay I'm sorry
does it matter yeah it does okay well
we're still listening in on what he has
to say so I honestly though in all
seriousness it's very very good game by
Xu see you know he's gonna lose a very
very very good game right I mean up
until that blunder he had played so many
accurate moves even with time oh okay
one more blender it was already lost at
that point no we didn't a very very good
good game from xqc held in that he's
there for a very long time if he'd seen
this pawn push to a5 instead of
Pondicherry I wasn't a pressure dude I
think I can think it's only because of
time in a normal 50-minute game I was
literally out of out of three games I've
seen
xec play this is by far and away the
best game that he played without a doubt
absolutely the best game not it not even
close and and that's a big compliment
given that he also had to come back from
such a tough loss last game so for him
to play this well and have that attitude
I'm the commander I'm chasing the candy
I respect that
yeah I I'm very impressed with the way
you played in this game obviously a very
difficult situation to be in certainly
but Queen each one is obviously checked
me here I don't really see much missing
that move but all in all I thought it
was very well played game by X you see
and and it's it's a tough loss but this
is the best player in his group so I
thought I thought he played um I thought
he played a very good game
absolutely and he's checking his his
analysis right after oh it's all because
of time and yeah he's just on time
situation was very
what time control does mostly doing
Street I ten minutes I think five
seconds or he plays bullet chess is one
minute he does see those both got it
well it takes some time to adjust to the
fast time control and I did show the
move that you were talking about instead
of g4 where was it okay right here so
when xqc played g4 the idea we were
talking about is if he had seen a five
here it would have been a lot trickier
black can't take the rook is hanging and
after rook takes the pawn takes b6 at
some point or you can even just keep the
pressure here then at least you're not
gonna end up losing that extra pawn and
if you open up these two files with the
two rooks you might get some kind of
counter play yeah I mean basically you
double the rooks and it would have been
very difficult for hutch to convert this
basically black is to bring the King all
the way over but it's it's very tricky
and I'm not sure the hutch would have
found it was the limited time on the
clock and he didn't get hutch very low
on the clock I mean at some point hutch
also only had two minutes so you know it
was impressive on his part as well than
he was able to play quickly and
accurately but we do expect that from
hunch he is an experienced player he's
very strong in one of the top players in
this tournament so congratulations to
him as well for this flight right yeah I
was it was it was a good one for hutch
very solid throughout the game and and
no real major mistakes oh I thought I
was also impressed from from hutch only
issue for hutch was I thought the time
usage like he uses too much time it
could it could affect him in some of the
matches in the champions bracket
potentially well we'll take a quick
break and then we'll be back with player
interviews chat we are live we're here
with hutch hutch congratulations for
that really nice performance there and
xqc put up a very good fight it wasn't
he over performed he had me nervous I
missed his pond take on f3 was it no I
was black it was a c6 yeah yeah I missed
that and once he got in there with the
Queen I got a little nervous with the
pond side pushes on the on the Queen
side but it ended up being okay because
I think he blundered pretty big at the
end there yeah once you got into the
time pressure he did end up blundering
but we noticed that you're also taking
your
at some point you're close to two
minutes when he had one minute where you
nervous at all that he might pull out an
upset no I was actually taking your
advice just to slow down and and look at
the board for a good minute or two just
to make sure that I have a decent
understanding what's happening
positionally mm-hmm and you do that very
well especially and I'm gonna pull it up
on the board when you brought your rook
to a7 so you saw the semi open file you
put pressure on his week square and I
think that was one of the key moments
when then you were able to bring your
pieces back into the game yeah I was
having some trouble figuring out how to
reactivate my night like he obviously
hates being that's like the worst
position for a knight on the board cuz
you can only attack two pieces or two
squares but I didn't want to pin I
didn't want to have my knight pin to my
rook I was worried about that
and so my decision-making had to do with
just avoiding that yeah that's that's
very fair and I mean we you already knew
that you were most likely going to make
it to the championship bracket because
even if you did end up getting an upset
I think you only needed a three point
five percent accuracy to move on to the
championship bracket which I certainly
would have been able to get okay yeah my
chat was telling me just to offer him a
draw and I said no no oh you didn't want
to be like voyboy no no no well I got
nervous with the math and I don't might
like he can't trust my chat so I just
decided to play it out know that C was
very fair and he card who is hutch going
to be paired up against in the next
bracket neat he'll NATO against Nate
Hale okay so do you have any predictions
for your match with Nate or what you're
thinking you're a strategy should be
there um I think I'm gonna win I'm just
gonna play it by ear
and figure it out I mean you are the
rating favorite and he's been playing
for less time than you so I think you
know just playing your solid chest does
seem like a very fair strategy and then
if you do win that game you're going to
end up playing the winner versus NIM
versus Papa platta NIM currently the
higher rated opponent but you would also
be a likely favorite in that situation
yeah in my mind I'm like I'm trying not
to get too overconfident but I'm
preparing for the championship match for
the final match
and so who would you hope to go up
against in the championship match
anybody BoBoiBoy but I mean I'd I would
like to play in though because he is a
good player and I think I would have fun
playing him or regardless and have you
guys done any practice games at all not
not even no not even a little bit oh wow
well he car do you have any tips for
what hutch should focus on in the
training from now until well I actually
a more general question actually which
was so so you've been on Twitch longer
than most other streamers and I think
you've been playing chess for a very
long time even even on stream so it's
kind of curious what your take is on all
of this and and many years later I mean
since you've been on so long how you
feel about saying chess explode like
this oh man I'm so thrilled
I think chess like I think chess can be
such a positive force in people's lives
it's like doing mental push-ups it
teaches you pattern recognition it can
help with your memory it can help with
your confidence because it's it's
something that if you work at you will
see improvement and and you'll notice it
in in really big ways I think especially
when you're at the lower level is I
think it's a bit easier to jump 200 300
400 points when you're like 800 or 900
rating yeah I wanted this to happen a
lot sooner I think we spoke about it
before but I'm so honestly shocked that
it hasn't happened sooner because chess
has such a huge massive global audience
so I felt like it was only a matter of
time and I'm glad to see it blowing up
right now I think it's a really really
good thing well we're lucky to have you
as part of the blow up thank you so much
for the interview and congratulations
again thank you very much appreciate it
guys good luck all right take care so we
got the two brackets here do not leave
yet chat because we are bringing on xqc
for an interview and he'll get some more
encouraging words from hikaru after a
very fantastic performance the best of
his pogchamp so far you know we have
Felix here hey
and I think we're switching scenes now
welcome Felix thanks so much for joining
us hikaru let him know how he felt about
in his game
yeah I thought out of altar games you
played in this first stage you you this
was the best game by far you played a
lot of very good moves for the first 15
20 moves the game
no no major mistakes and and then once
you got low as some mistakes occurred
but still overall you played you played
very well so I thought I thought it's a
good performance mmm Thanks
what uh deep did h-how'd even attack
like how do you do anything that does
anything in I feel like you're just
running in circles so so basically
Alexander's can go to the position
before he played 95 yeah here we go
there there two points so first of all
in this position this is the first point
I'll point out the way that you want to
play here is you want to open up space
for your rooks on these these middle
lanes basically so the way you would do
that as you move the rook over to this
dark square to start with let's just say
black I don't know pushes you play h6
Alexandra mm-hmm and then you play like
Knight to a4 trade the bishops let's
just say black moves to work back to b8
and the way you play is like what you
want to do is open up space your rook so
you can push the pawn forward here and
you you wanna you want to open up these
these files for your rooks to attack on
because your rooks are perfectly placed
here okay so so basically the hardest
part of the games once you develop like
the Knights and the bishops is how to
bring your rooks into the game and you
want to have them on these open open
lines basically that was the first thing
and then one other thing that you you
you actually you mention it when you're
doing your analysis much later
kyouda seiichi for I was Sandra mm-hmm
okay right here right and so you mention
this on your stream um and then you
didn't do it was that you could have
pushed this pawn here to this the square
on the side of the board
because if pawn takes pawn you take the
take the black rook okay pawn pawn takes
pawn takes blood yeah yeah that played
yeah because you actually mentioned it
before he pushed his pawn forward one
square in the center of the board and
then then then you then you lost the
train of thought you didn't play it but
this would have been a great move and
you would have had you would have been
in the game and had a chance to win
because if your opponent just waits here
keeps licking six Alexandra mm-hmm I
thought works
I thought if I took pawn she took with
Knights then
then I'm baited
right but the point is you don't
actually take the pond you can actually
put more pressure on this pond by
putting both your rooks on you can stack
the rooks here click rook b3 Alexandre
yeah I was just moving arrows but I can
I can also play the moves let's say King
d6 and then you bring your other rook
into the game also so now his pawn is
still pinned and you're putting even
more pressure on it oh okay yeah this
was a pretty sneaky plan to play I know
that you were talking a lot about the
time pressure do you think that was the
biggest factor in the endgame there yeah
honestly listen I don't have that
mentality very often but I was like dude
I made this far I'm glad did like yes
like a like higher rated and II like DD
I'm like did I was I was falling apart
the end I think about like in one minute
there's no way I can sit you know if you
do those puzzles over and over again it
you cannot build those like patterns
like you see it happen in front of you
like a carpet rolling down it right but
I don't have that I have to have to
manually think and that's a lot needed
same thing is expensive is not to think
and that's it like you know it's time
and with a minute six as you know I was
like dude there's no I can think every
turn and actually better than he will
because he sees the club it'll be rolled
out Gil yeah I mean you're playing
against a higher rated opponent so the
fact that you're able to go so far not
make any serious mistakes in the opening
and then only choked at the end when you
had very little time is super impressive
that was one of the best possible
scenarios of the game here and we were
talking about it before as well hmm
yeah this is kind of like that when
you're a long time or what fast chess is
that like thinking is an expensive
maneuver right and every time you think
you kind of lose you kind of like like
anything you sit down and you actually
thinking it's not like already pre-plan
ideas whatever you lose on time and then
it's more expensive and more and more
and more and then you can be getting
less right mm-hmm and actually you were
talking about that in the middle game
too at some point because you weren't
sure how to make progress when you you
just brought your rook over to d1 when
the position was really close and you
actually came to the correct conclusion
you said something like I don't think
this is the best
but I have to play quickly and that's
what you usually want to do when you get
to about two minutes just make decent
moves that are fast instead of trying to
look for perfect moves yeah yeah it's
why it's why my my mental I was going to
flamenco boomin cuz that was like you
know yes time and he sees them coming
you know it's okay yeah no I was just
gonna add like in general though the one
good thing is if you play like this you
certainly are gonna have a chance in the
upcoming bracket are you are you looking
forward to playing at someone who who's
about the same level that you're at
because in this game this was someone
who's played a lot more chess than you
have oh yeah but I'm gonna do this
record right yeah you're playing against
fus in the first round so are you
excited to play it play against someone
where you're gonna I'm sorry guess what
FUS lee boost lee loosen her rating is
around 800 so you guys are very similar
rating wise
I took a I'll do all the bills that have
a appraisal bit of puzzle but a little
bit a little bit of coaching with my
main man I'm in Haru did okay and
loosely if loosely will not be a
challenge Wilma what listen oh I've been
around comparisons long enough okay
after been nothing no that loose
brackets no stress good losers bracket
it's part of the processes but it's part
of the commitment you lose bracket
you're grinding all the way up and
people don't see you you're under in the
shadows in the shores dig dig dig dig do
it and by the time I forget boom come on
Soares first place might one cinema for
a quick that's the attitude we want to
hear thank you so much for being here in
the interview and I'm really looking
forward to seeing your games in the
consolation bracket yep thanks I mean
sure see goodbye alright well that was
such a nice note to finish up on he's
going to be taking on foosley
June 17th at 2 p.m. Pacific so that's
three days from now chat make sure
you're following chess come on Twitch
just so that you know when these games
go live and you know not just because
I'm here as a commentator and I have to
say this or I'll get fired you better
follow chat because I have a quota and
if it doesn't get completed then I'm out
my job safety is on you no pressure
alright
thank you so much that was a lot of fun
honestly today I think was was a lot of
buses I think certainly one thing that I
really enjoyed not just today but also I
think was yesterday as well just saying
like even I mean technically even though
II robbed one that yeah mystery of
course I mean boy boys being generous
but when you see people like I robbed in
the first in the first three games now
you see some like X you see a struggle
seeing them have this positive attitude
and sort of being able to smile
realizing that they're gonna have a shot
in the in the in the in the loser's
bracket it's just great to see in it you
feel like there there's gonna be a
Redemption arc in that bracket we don't
know who it's gonna be for but I think
for sure we're gonna see the redemption
art so it's gonna be a lot of fun to
watch absolutely so with today we have
our completion of the four player four
groups we are now going to move on to
the brackets chat it's going to be even
more exciting because players are going
to get paired with people closer to
their rating range so we're gonna see
some crazier closer games chat hang
around because we are rating xqc go show
them some love you guys thanks so much
everybody who tuned in and take care